So let us try our hand at computing
some reliability and availability.
Suppose that the system we
are considering is just a hard disk.
And this disk, we buy it.
We put it in our machine and
now, it works fine for
12 months and then it breaks
because it cannot spin any more.
And then it takes us one month to
replace the motor in the disk.
And after that fix,
it works fine for about four months.
And then it breaks again and
we find that the problem is
that it can not move heads, and
it took us two months to figure that
out and then get the heads unstuck.
And now the disc works fine for
14 months.
And then it breaks.
And we find that the head has broken.
And we find this quickly but
then realize it will take
us 3 months to fix it.
So we throw this disk away and
buy a new one.
So the questions for you are,
what is the MTTF for this disk,
what is the MTTR for this disk, and
what is the availability of this
disk expressed as a percentage?